un jour deux parades annuelles dans
cette petite ville de l'arizona célèbre
la mémoire de rex arlene une gloire
locale de la musique et la politique
n'est jamais très loin
oui ici on fait même campagne pour
devenir juge l'avocate sanderson se
présente pour siéger à la cour
supérieure du comté
rien de surprenant des juges se font
élire dans une majorité d'états
américains mais en fait financer une
campagne électorale coûte cher est ce
qu'on pourrait alors acheté une juge
impossible dit elle d'accepter
personnellement de l'argent
cela se fait par l'entremise d'un
trésorier non loin de là un autre
candidat au même poste de juge affiche
davantage sa couleur politique
même si le poste n'est pas partisan mais
alors pourquoi s'afficher comme tels
abris baril à ce bye bye
tout le monde a des préjugés sur bien
des sujets dit jason strom mais cela ne
devrait pas influencer nos décisions
aux côtés des juges les électeurs
peuvent aussi choisir leur chérif
l'équivalent d'un chef de police jerry
dunn est sorti de sa retraite pour
reprendre du service
même s'il n'aime pas jouer aux
politiciens et quêter de l'argent dans
les marcheurs que ce cadre majeur frais
s'il est élu il serait à la tête de plus
de 3000 employés et d'un budget de près
d'un demi milliard de dollars américains
lui aussi est identifié au parti
républicain
parce qu'il n'a pas le choix il conway
ses partisans voteront d'ailleurs pour
lui justement grâce à son affiliation
politique
mais se faire élire comporte aussi son
lot de confrontation cela fait partie de
la démocratie dit senderos aux lois de
la course à la maison blanche la parade
des candidats qui influenceront tout
autant la vie de ces électeurs se
poursuit jusqu'au 3 novembre
ici frédéric arnould de radio canada
wilcox en arizona